There's this guy who did this thing that's extraordinary. He tried to live like a badger. And I say that in this wasn't a stunt, and he's not a crazy person. This was a sincere, thoughtful attempt to figure something out.
有个人做了一件非同寻常的事。他尝试像獾一样生活。我这么说并非指这是一种噱头，他也不是个疯子。这是一个真诚且经过深思熟虑的尝试，为了弄明白一些事情。
The guy's name is Charles Foster. And his interest in this kind of thing really all began when he was a kid. He says a blackbird used to come into his family's suburban backyard. And he would look at it through the window of his house and stare in its eye, and it would look back at him. And he would think to himself, I know this backyard so well, but the bird knows stuff about it I don't. The bird knows all kinds of things I don't.
这个人名叫查尔斯·福斯特。他对这类事情的兴趣实际上始于他小时候。他说，过去常有一只黑鸫来到他家郊区的后院。他会透过家里的窗户看着它，凝视它的眼睛，它也会回望他。他会心想，我对这个后院了如指掌，但那只鸟却知道一些我不知道的事情。那只鸟知道各种我不知道的东西。
And I wanted to know what that was.
而我想知道那是什么。
And you write that you went to the library, reading everything you could on it. You mapped all the nests in your area. And you would visit them every day. And you took notes. You had a notebook where you were basically gathering your field notes.
你写道，你去了图书馆，阅读了所有能找到的相关资料。你绘制了你所在地区所有的巢穴地图。你每天都会去探访它们。而且你做了笔记。你有一个笔记本，基本上是在收集你的实地考察记录。
Yeah. I was a fanatical note-taker, a fanatical mapper. I did things which, no doubt, would sound really strange or macabre now.
是的。我是一个狂热的笔记记录者和测绘者。我所做的事情，现在听起来无疑是非常奇怪或阴森的。
Like for instance, he taxidermied a dead blackbird he found. As a kid, he did this.
例如，他把自己发现的一只死黑鸫制成了标本。小时候，他做过这种事。
Mounted with its wings outspread, and it dangled over my bed. I used to watch it circling as I went to sleep at night.
把它翅膀展开安装好，让它悬挂在我的床上方。晚上睡觉时，我常看着它盘旋。
Hm.
嗯。
So yeah. And also I pickled in formalin a blackbird's brain and put it in a jar, and I would sometimes go to bed holding it in my hand.
所以，是的。我还用福尔马林腌制了一只黑鸫的脑子，把它装进罐子里，有时我会握着它睡觉。
He'd peer into it the way that you do when you're a kid, imagining, hoping something of the bird would seep into him. He'd fall asleep wishing he'd be a blackbird in his dreams.
他会像孩子那样盯着它看，想象着，希望那只鸟的一部分能渗入到自己体内。他会带着希望在梦中成为黑鸫的愿望入睡。
And as an adult, his fascination with animals continued. He became a veterinarian.
成年后，他对动物的痴迷仍在继续。他成为了一名兽医。
Can I ask, when you became a vet, was part of it because you wanted to get closer to animals? You wanted to understand them better?
我可以问一下吗，当你成为兽医时，部分原因是因为你想更接近动物吗？你想更好地了解它们吗？
It was exactly that.
正是如此。
Yeah.
是的。
I felt that, by putting my hands physically on animals, by knowing how they worked as machines, I would understand better those really mystical questions which I posed myself as a child.
我觉得，通过亲手接触动物，通过了解它们作为机器是如何运作的，我能更好地理解那些我在孩童时期向自己提出的非常神秘的问题。
Didn't work. If anything, he says, understanding animals as machines took him even further from the thing he was interested in. How do they perceive the world? What do they know?
没用。他说，如果说有什么的话，那就是把动物理解为机器让他离他感兴趣的东西更远了。它们是如何感知世界的？它们知道些什么？
And so, as an adult, he began to venture out into the woods to try to live as different animals. He documented this in a book called Being a Beast . The most interesting section in this book is his attempt to live like a badger. Usually he would do this alone, though for a few days he went with his eight-year-old son, Tom. On a friend's farm, they made a human-sized badger home. This was a tunnel, 15-feet long, that they would sleep in. Charles says he's probably spent six weeks living underground like this over the years, sleeping during the day, awake at night like real badgers.
因此，成年后，他开始冒险进入森林，尝试像不同的动物一样生活。他在一本名为《像野兽一样》的书中记录了这一点。书中这部分最有趣的内容是他尝试像獾一样生活。通常他独自进行，不过有几天他和八岁的儿子汤姆一起。在朋友的农场里，他们造了一个人大小的獾穴。这是一个15英尺长的隧道，他们就在里面睡觉。查尔斯说，这些年来他大概花了六周时间像这样生活在地下，白天睡觉，晚上像真正的獾一样活动。
And the main part of living like a badger was being low to the ground, crawling around on their hands and knees, which he knows how weird that sounds. And they did something that's so simple but changes everything. Instead of using their eyes to get around-- badgers' eyesight is terrible-- they'd blindfold themselves and use their noses.
而像獾一样生活的主要部分是身体贴近地面，手膝着地爬行，他知道这听起来有多奇怪。而且他们做了一件非常简单但改变了一切的事情。他们没有用眼睛来观察周围——獾的视力很差——而是蒙上眼睛，改用鼻子。
When you move your nose over a small area of the forest floor, just move it an inch and you get a completely different set of smells. The ground is much, much more interesting when you smell it than when you look at it.
当你把鼻子移过森林地面的一小块区域时，只需移动一英寸，你就会闻到完全不同的一系列气味。当你用嗅觉感知地面时，它比你用眼睛去看要有趣得多、多得多。
And then everything changes when rain comes. Just describe how different the entire place is when rain finally hits.
而且下雨时一切都会改变。描述一下当雨水真正落下时，整个地方有多么不同。
Rain unlocks scent. So there's a massive explosion for olfactory animals of the intensity of the place. It was like the volume suddenly being turned on. And not just volume. It was a better sort of music. It was like switching to Mozart after you'd been having the piped music in the mall. It was incredibly exciting.
雨水释放了气味。所以对于依靠嗅觉的动物来说，这地方的气味强度会产生巨大的爆发。就像音量突然被调大了一样。而且不仅仅是音量。那是更好的一种音乐。就像你一直在商场里听背景音乐，突然切换到了莫扎特。这令人难以置信地兴奋。
He says it only took a few days for him and his son to be able to navigate the landscape in the woods blindfolded, using only their noses. Oak trees were good landmarks, he says, because surprisingly, they all smell different from each other. I asked him to read this passage from the book describing what the oak smelled like on those outings.
他说，他和儿子只用了几天时间，就能蒙着眼睛，仅靠鼻子在森林里导航。他说，橡树是很好的地标，因为令人惊讶的是，它们每棵闻起来都不一样。我让他读了书中描述那些短途旅行中橡树气味的一段。
"Out of the tunnel, turn right. 15 yards; raw tobacco, mostly Turkish; straight on. After half a minute, wall of limes and sick in front."
“出洞口，右转。15码；生烟草味，主要是土耳其烟草；直走。半分钟后，面前是一堵酸橙和呕吐物的墙。”
"If I had to pick one word for the badger's experience, it would be 'intimate.' Grass and bracken stems brush your face. When you're forcing a new path, the stems graze. Water shudders off grass into your eyes. Things slide away. We bustled and grunted and elbowed and pushed and pressed our noses into the ground. And even we smelled something-- the citrusy piss of the voles; the distantly maritime tang of a slug trail, like a winter rock pool; the sharp musk of a weasel; the blunter musk of an otter."
“如果非要用一个词来形容獾的体验，那应该是‘亲密’。草和蕨类植物的茎刷过你的脸。当你强行开辟一条新路时，茎部会擦伤你。水从草叶上颤抖着落入你的眼睛。东西滑走。我们忙碌着、咕哝着、用肘部推挤，并将鼻子压入地面。即使是我们也能闻到一些东西——田鼠那柑橘味的小便；蛞蝓痕迹那遥远的海洋气息，就像冬天的岩石水池；鼬鼠那尖锐的麝香味；水獭那更沉闷的麝香味。”
It got to the point where his eight-year-old son one day declared, I can smell mice, and then he headed off into the distance and found-- OK, not mice, but another kind of rodent-- bank voles.
以至于有一天他八岁的儿子宣布，我能闻到老鼠的味道，然后他就向远处跑去，找到了——好吧，不是老鼠，而是另一种啮齿动物——红背䶄。
I can't talk about this book without having Charles Foster read one more excerpt. Badgers eat earthworms, so he felt compelled to at least try them. And he tried a bunch, from all over. He would put them into his mouth alive and feel them try to escape by wriggling through the gaps in his teeth, and then he'd bite.
如果不让查尔斯·福斯特再读一段摘录，我就无法谈论这本书。獾吃蚯蚓，所以他觉得必须至少尝尝它们。他试过很多种，来自各地。他会把活蚯蚓放进嘴里，感受它们试图通过牙缝扭动逃跑，然后他就咬下去。
"Earthworms taste of slime and the land. Worms from Chablis have a long, mineral finish. Worms from Picardy are musty; they taste of decay and splintered wood. Worms from the high Kent Weald are fresh and uncomplicated; they'd appear in the list recommended with a grilled sole. About 85% of an average badger's diet is earthworms. This fact both drains badgers of some of their charisma and makes them excitingly inaccessible."
“蚯蚓尝起来有黏液和泥土的味道。来自夏布利的蚯蚓余味悠长，有矿物质感。来自皮卡第的蚯蚓带有霉味；它们尝起来有腐烂和碎木头的味道。来自肯特高地威尔德的蚯蚓新鲜而纯粹；它们会出现在推荐搭配烤鳎鱼的菜单上。獾平均饮食中约85%是蚯蚓。这一事实既让獾失去了一些魅力，又让它们变得令人兴奋地难以捉摸。”
Are those real flavors that you're describing, or are you just riffing on different potential tastes of the worms of Chablis?
你描述的那些是真实的味道，还是你只是在随意联想夏布利蚯蚓可能具有的味道？
No, no. Those are real flavors.
不，不。那些是真实的味道。
And then sometimes you would eat them raw and sometimes cooked?
而且有时你会生吃它们，有时会煮熟吃？
Yeah. And I recommend, if anyone wants to do this, that they cook them and they have them with garlic.
是的。如果有人想尝试的话，我建议把它们煮熟，然后配上大蒜一起吃。
Charles Foster isn't just a veterinarian. He's also a practicing lawyer, and he teaches at Oxford University in England. And when he writes about the question that is at the heart of his interest with animals-- the question, what can we really understand about an animal's experience-- he parses what we can and cannot know with a lawyer's precision. He is meticulous. And he has thought about this a lot.
查尔斯·福斯特不仅是一名兽医。他还是一位执业律师，并在英国牛津大学任教。当他写到他关注动物的核心问题——即我们到底能理解多少动物的体验——时，他以律师的严谨剖析了我们能知和不能知的事物。他一丝不苟。而且他对此思考了很多。
He says, of course we can't know what animals think, how they conceive of themselves, how they conceive of the world. We can't really know what they feel. But with many animals, he says, we can know their physical experience because we share so much physiology with so many animals-- our limbs and eyes and noses and mouths and the way our nerves work.
他说，我们当然无法知道动物在想什么，它们如何看待自己，如何看待世界。我们无法真正知道它们的感觉。但他说，对于许多动物，我们可以知道它们的身体体验，因为我们与许多动物共享太多的生理构造——我们的四肢、眼睛、鼻子、嘴巴以及我们神经运作的方式。
And that's why he tried to live like animals live. Putting his own body, his own physiology, into a badger's landscape seemed like his best chance of getting a tiny glimpse of what it might feel like to be a badger.
这就是为什么他尝试像动物一样生活。将他自己的身体、他自己的生理机能置于獾的景观中，似乎是他获得对獾的感觉有一丁点了解的最好机会。
What are the moments that you feel like you got closest to the thing you were seeking?
哪些时刻让你觉得最接近你所追求的东西？
There was the moment of-- there was the moment when I said to myself, there's a tree there because there's the smell of a tree, rather than there's a tree there because I looked at it last Thursday and I know that it should be.
有这样一个时刻——有这样一个时刻，我对自己说，那里有一棵树，是因为有树的味道，而不是因为上周四我看到了它，所以我知道它应该在那里。
Mostly this did not work. He's the first to point that out. As soon as he would stand up and see the world again with his head 6 feet in the air, it all went away. The visual world reasserted itself. His head filled with thoughts that a badger would never think.
大多数时候这并没有奏效。他是第一个指出这一点的人。一旦他站起来，头部距离地面6英尺，再次用眼睛看世界，一切就都消失了。视觉世界重新确立了地位。他的脑海里充满了獾永远不会想的思想。
But I could understand why he gave so many years to this project, even though he knew all along it was such a long shot. It's too exciting to leave yourself and try to be something so different.
但我能理解他为什么在这个项目上投入了这么多年，尽管他从一开始就知道这希望渺茫。离开自己，试图成为某种完全不同的东西，这太让人兴奋了。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Becoming a Badger. We have two stories for you about trying to become something you are not. One of these stories is about a guy from France. One is about a dog. In each of the stories, they set out to become different from what they are, and they do it by just jumping into the new identity, into the new thing they want to be, pretending to be that thing, and hoping it sticks. Stay with us.
好的，来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“成为一只獾”。我们有两个关于尝试成为你本身以外的东西的故事。其中一个故事是关于一个来自法国的家伙。另一个是关于一条狗。在每个故事中，他们都着手去成为与自己不同的人，他们通过直接跳入新的身份，跳入他们想要成为的新事物，假装自己就是那个东西，并希望这能奏效。请留在我们身边。
Act One, Je Suis Ici Toute La Semaine.
第一幕，Je Suis Ici Toute La Semaine。
So I heard about this guy. His name is Gad Elmaleh, and he's basically the most famous stand-up comedian in France. He plays arenas in France. He gets mobbed everywhere by fans and paparazzi, yadda, yadda. Yadda, yadda's actually appropriate. Gad is known as the Jerry Seinfeld of France. Just to give you a sense, this is the beginning of one of his most popular concert videos. It's from 2010.
所以我听说过这个家伙。他的名字叫加德·艾尔马莱，他基本上是法国最著名的单口喜剧演员。他在法国的体育场演出。他到处被粉丝和狗仔队围堵，等等等等。其实用“等等等等”很合适。加德被称为法国的杰瑞·宋飞。为了让你有个概念，这是他最受欢迎的演唱会视频之一的开头。那是2010年的。
[MUSIC - "DON'T STOP 'TIL YOU GET ENOUGH" BY MICHAEL JACKSON]
[音乐 - 迈克尔·杰克逊的《DON'T STOP 'TIL YOU GET ENOUGH》]
[CROWD SCREAMING]
[人群尖叫]
Yes, that's a Michael Jackson song they got the rights to. Gad does this rock star thing where his silhouette hits the stage before he does, and then his silhouette dances around to the music, tantalizing the crowd until the spotlight hits him.
是的，那是他们获得了版权的迈克尔·杰克逊的歌。加德在做这种摇滚明星范儿的事情，他的剪影先于他本人出现在舞台上，然后他的剪影随着音乐跳舞，撩拨着人群，直到聚光灯打在他身上。
Bonsoir!
晚上好！
Here's how famous he is. His initial jokes are about being famous-- how freaked out his fans get, meeting somebody as famous as he is. But about a year ago, Gad embarked on this quest. He decided he was going to try to make it as a successful comic here in America in English.
他有多出名呢。他最初的笑话是关于自己出名的——他的粉丝在见到像他这么出名的人时有多惊慌。但大约一年前，加德踏上了这次探索。他决定他要尝试在美国用英语成为一名成功的喜剧演员。
This is an incredibly difficult and totally unnecessary thing for anybody to try to do. In France, everybody knows Gad Elmaleh. It's going great for him. And he's giving all that up to start again at the bottom, doing small clubs and venues. He has to reinvent how he does his whole job. And he's struggling. It's simultaneously audacious and very humble.
对任何人来说，这都是一件极其困难且完全没必要的事情。在法国，每个人都认识加德·艾尔马莱。他在那里发展得很好。他却放弃了这一切，从底层重新开始，在小型俱乐部和场馆演出。他必须彻底重新发明他做这份工作的方式。他正在挣扎。这既大胆又非常谦逊。
I have to say, I'm kind of a sucker for somebody who decides to do something really hard that nobody wants but them just because they can't help themselves. And that is what this is. And what is funny in France to French people, you will not be surprised to hear, is not the same as what is funny in English to American people. So to succeed at this, Gad has to understand the exact contours of what is different between the sense of humor of these two entirely different countries while he's on stage. He has to do this live while trying to entertain paying customers.
我不得不说，我有点偏爱那种因为无法控制自己，而决定去做一些没人想要但只有他们自己想做的非常困难的事情的人。而这正是现在的状况。而在法国让法国人觉得好笑的东西，不用说，你也会猜到，和在美国让美国人觉得好笑的东西是不一样的。所以为了成功，加德必须在台上的时候，准确地理解这两个完全不同的国家的幽默感之间的细微差别。他必须在现场尝试娱乐付费观众的同时做到这一点。
Reporter Zack McDermott is the one who first told us about Gad. Zack is a comedy nerd and a former stand-up himself. He takes the story from here.
记者扎克·麦克德莫特是第一个告诉我们加德情况的人。扎克是个喜剧书呆子，以前自己也是做单口喜剧的。他从这里开始讲述这个故事。
The only reason I know who Gad Elmaleh is is because of my wife. She's Belgian. I'll call her Aurelie because, although we've been married for three years, I still can't pronounce her name right.
我之所以知道加德·艾尔马莱是谁，是因为我妻子。她是比利时人。我会称呼她为奥蕾莉，因为尽管我们已经结婚三年了，但我仍然无法准确地读出她的名字。
Aurelie.
奥蕾莉。
Once again.
再说一次。
Aurelie.
奥蕾莉。
Anyway. For her, Gad Elmaleh was a household name growing up.
总之。对她来说，加德·艾尔马莱是她成长过程中的家喻户晓的名字。
And you know, it's funny because there are a few of his jokes that are so famous that if you say one sentence, everybody knows that you're referring to him. I thought about that. There is something about learning English, and the sentence Brian is in the kitchen--
而且你知道，这很有趣，因为他有几个笑话太出名了，如果你说出一句话，每个人都知道你指的是他。我思考过这个问题。学习英语这件事有点东西，还有“布莱恩在厨房里”那句话——
It's a routine he does about learning English as a kid and the random phrases he had to repeat over and over again, like, where is Brian?
这是他关于小时候学英语的一个段子，以及他不得不一遍又一遍重复的随机短语，比如，“布莱恩在哪里？”
Where is Brian? [FRENCH], Brian is in the kitchen.
“布莱恩在哪里？”[法语]，布莱恩在厨房里。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I mean, I remember my friends, when I was maybe like 15, 16, or maybe a little older-- everybody was saying that. It's like, what is it in English? Like, that's what she said. It's like that. Everybody says that.
我的意思是，我记得我的朋友们，在我大概15、16岁的时候，或者可能大一点的时候——每个人都在说那个。这就像，英语里是什么？就像“那是她说的”。就像那样。每个人都这么说。
That's what she said.
“那是她说的”。
Yeah.
是的。
That's my producer, Sean Cole, by the way. You'll be hearing his voice a bit, too, as we go.
顺便说一下，那是我的制作人肖恩·科尔。随着节目的进行，你也会听到他的声音。
So Aurelie was really excited when Gad moved to New York and started doing shows here. She drug me to a couple of them, including a very early gig last September at a performance space called Joe's Pub. It's not a bar. It's kind of a highbrow New York Cabaret space, and it's cozy. Seats less than 200.
所以当加德搬到纽约并开始在这里演出时，奥蕾莉真的很兴奋。她硬拉着我去看他的几场演出，包括去年九月在一家名为乔酒吧的表演空间里进行的一场非常早期的演出。那不是酒吧。那更像是一个高雅的纽约歌舞空间，而且很舒适。座位不到200个。
Even just seeing him in such a small venue, it's such a treat. And it's like, wow, how lucky French people are. You're like, that's great.
即使只是在这么小的场馆见到他，也是一种享受。而且你会觉得，哇，法国人真幸运。你会觉得，那太棒了。
I know. It's like seeing like--
我知道。就像看到……
Sort of like VIP when you do that.
你做那种事的时候就像是贵宾。
You feel like VIP.
你感觉自己像贵宾。
You really do, yeah.
真的，是的。
It's like seeing Neil Young play at a bar or something.
就像看到尼尔·杨在酒吧演出之类的。
I don't know who that is, but sure.
我不知道那是谁，但好吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Joe's Pub is now proud to present Gad Elmaleh.
乔酒吧现在很荣幸地呈现加德·艾尔马莱。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
This was, hands down, the best-looking and best-dressed crowd for a comedy show I've ever seen. So many scarves. Such tight jeans. The women looked great, too. The room was mostly French, with some Moroccan fans spackled in, as well. Gad's ethnically Moroccan, and he grew up there, so most of the room knew his French act.
这绝对是我见过的喜剧表演中最好看、穿着最讲究的观众。围巾真多。牛仔裤真紧。女士们看起来也很棒。房间里大部分是法国人，零星夹杂着一些摩洛哥粉丝。加德是摩洛哥裔，他在那里长大，所以房间里大多数人都知道他的法语表演。
Is he really gonna do this in English? Yeah! Oh, wow. I don't know why I'm doing this. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
他真的要用英语做这个吗？是的！哦，哇。我不知道我为什么要这样做。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。
The first thing you notice about Gad is that he's got incredible stage presence. And he's a very physical comedian. One minute he's all elegance and grace, the next he chimps up his face and flops around. His English act is basically observational comedy, including a lot of outsiders' impressions of America and, specifically, New York. For instance, he says he likes to ask directions of Americans because they always include Starbucks.
关于加德，你注意到的第一件事是他有令人难以置信的舞台表现力。他是一位非常有肢体动作的喜剧演员。前一分钟他还是优雅和风度翩翩，下一分钟他就做出猴子脸，四处乱倒。他的英语表演基本上是观察式喜剧，包括很多局外人对美国，特别是纽约的印象。例如，他说他喜欢向美国人问路，因为他们总是会提到星巴克。
You want to go straight, then there's a Starbucks on your left. You make a right. The next block there's two Starbucks. You make another right. There's another block with another one Starbucks. Make a left at the other block. There's no Starbucks, so don't panic.
你想要直走，然后在你左边有个星巴克。你向右转。下一个街区有两个星巴克。你再向右转。下个街区还有一个星巴克。在另一个街区左转。没有星巴克，所以别慌。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Asking directions in France is different.
在法国问路是不同的。
And this bleeds into another staple of his show, which I'll call, Americans be like this, French people be like that. Here's a joke about shopping in New York and this one, over-the-top, earnest sales guy.
这又引出了他演出的另一个主打内容，我可以称之为“美国人是这样，法国人是那样”。这是一个关于在纽约购物以及这个超级夸张、一本正经的销售员的笑话。
And he told me something you'll never hear in France. Let me double check.
他告诉了我一些你在法国永远听不到的话。让我仔细核对一下。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
In France, we don't even have single-check!
在法国，我们甚至连单人结账都没有！
You can tell from response in the room that this isn't exactly an away game for Gad. The French and Moroccan folks in the audience love him unconditionally, but even here, in front of the friendliest possible crowd, it's a rough show. There are jokes that just don't go anywhere.
你可以从房间里的反应看出，这对加德来说并不完全是一场客场比赛。观众中的法国和摩洛哥人无条件地爱他，但即使在这里，在面对最友好的观众时，这也是一场艰难的演出。有些笑话根本没人笑。
A friend of mine, he said, I am a fundamentalist atheist--
我有个朋友，他说，我是个原教旨主义的无神论者——
A fundamentalist atheist.
一个原教旨主义的无神论者。
I said, what the [BLEEP] is that? It's like if you're ordering a triple-shot espresso, but decaf. I like this one, but I will have to work on it.
我说，那他妈的是什么？就像你点了一杯三份浓缩咖啡，但要无咖啡因的。我喜欢这个，但我得改进一下。
He said this a few times. OK. I have to work on that joke. He had a notepad on his stool, and he'd occasionally jot down which jokes worked and which didn't.
他说了好几次。好的。我得改进那个笑话。他在凳子上放了一个笔记本，他偶尔会记下哪些笑话有效，哪些无效。
OK. Good joke, bad delivery.
好的。笑话很好，表达很烂。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's OK. Let's be humble tonight. It's a work in progress. More work than progress, but it's OK.
没关系。今晚要谦虚一点。这是一个进行中的工作。进展少，工作多，但没关系。
He's done other gigs in front of audiences that don't know him where he bombed. It's something that just doesn't happen to him in France these days. Imagine doing something 5,000 times, and on the 5,001st time, you suck. It's not a good feeling.
他在其他观众不认识他的地方演出过，那里他搞砸了。这在他现在法国简直不可能发生。想象一下你做过5000次某件事，在第5001次时，你却搞砸了。这感觉可不好。
That feeling like if you wear a sweater and you're all wet on your body right after the shower. And you put the-- agh, eugh, algh. You just want to hide. Yeah, I bombed some nights.
那种感觉就像你穿着毛衣，刚洗完澡身体还是湿的。然后你穿上……啊，呃，哎。你只想躲起来。是的，我有些晚上搞砸了。
To be honest, I had so many moments where I was, oh my god, how am I gonna do this? I had so many moments writing, crafting last-minute jokes in front of a club, alone, and like, what am I doing?
说实话，我有很多时刻觉得，天哪，我该怎么做？我有很多时刻在写剧本，在俱乐部前临时创作笑话，独自一人，心想，我在做什么？
Good question. Why is he doing this? Onstage, he jokes that he's doing it because he needed to challenge himself, which is only partly a joke. In France, he's reached this weird level of fame where his fans laugh at everything. He told me it doesn't matter what he says anymore.
好问题。他为什么要这么做？在台上，他开玩笑说他这么做是因为他需要挑战自己，这只是半开玩笑。在法国，他已经达到了那种奇怪的知名度，粉丝们对他说的任何话都笑。他告诉我，他说什么已经不重要了。
With the people who know me, it's like, oh, heh. They always some, heh. And I don't like that.
对于认识我的人来说，就像，哦，呵。他们总是会，呵。我不喜欢那样。
They kind of give you a pass.
他们算是给你面子。
Yeah.
是的。
It's not satisfying, he says. It's too easy. But working here-- it's hard again, and that's what he likes about it.
他说，这不满足。太容易了。但在美国工作——又变得困难了，而这就是他喜欢的地方。
I'm excited. I wake up in the morning. I can't wait for the night to perform exactly like it was 20 years ago when I began doing stand-up in France because it was new. Like everything, you know? Like relationship. Like a gum, you know? Gum-- you just put it in your mouth. It's full of sugar. This is now.
我很兴奋。我早上醒来。我迫不及待地想等到晚上去表演，就像我20年前在法国刚开始做单口喜剧时那样，因为它是新的。就像所有事情，你知道吗？就像一段关系。就像口香糖，你知道吗？口香糖——你刚放进嘴里。它充满了糖。这是现在。
Is that what happened in France? There was no more sugar in your gum?
法国发生过那种事吗？你的口香糖里没糖了？
No more sugar in my gum. So we need to bring back the sugar in our gum.
我的口香糖里没糖了。所以我们需要把糖带回我们的口香糖里。
But Gad's friend Dan Naturman believes there's another reason Gad wants to make it in English. Dan's one of the few comics who's gone the other direction. He's an American who sometimes performs in French-- in Paris and Montreal.
但加德的朋友丹·纳特曼认为，加德想用英语取得成功还有另一个原因。丹是少数反方向发展的喜剧演员之一。他是个美国人，有时用法语表演——在巴黎和蒙特利尔。
For any French comic-- and I've spent enough time talking to them-- they don't feel like they've conquered comedy until they've conquered America, because this is perceived as the home of stand-up comedy. You ask a French comic, who are your idols, you're more likely to hear Louis CK, Chris Rock. So in that sense, he feels like, OK. I did well in France, but am I really a great comedian if I haven't conquered America? I think he's somewhat insecure in that regard. I think, deep in his heart, he's saying, but I'm not Louis CK. I'm not Seinfeld. I want to be those guys, or as close as I can get. And the only way to do that is to come here.
对于任何法国喜剧演员——我花了很多时间跟他们聊天——他们觉得除非征服了美国，否则就不算征服了喜剧，因为这里被视为单口喜剧的大本营。你问一个法国喜剧演员，谁是你的偶像，你更有可能听到路易·CK，克里斯·洛克。所以从这个意义上说，他觉得，好的。我在法国做得很好，但如果我没有征服美国，我是伟大的喜剧演员吗？我觉得他在那方面有点不安全感。我觉得，在他内心深处，他在说，但我不是路易·CK。我不是宋飞。我想成为那些人，或者尽可能接近他们。而做到这一点的唯一方法就是来这里。
Can he get there?
他能做到吗？
It's gonna be a rough one, isn't it?
这会很难，不是吗？
We played a recording of that quote for Gad.
我们给加德播放了那段引语的录音。
It's not easy to hear, but it doesn't hurt.
听起来不容易，但不伤人。
Is it true?
是真的吗？
Yeah, it's true. Because if you're a great soccer player in America, you want to be with the Real de Madrid. You want to be with Barcelona. You want to be with Bayern de Munich. You want to be with Arsenal.
是的，是真的。因为如果你是美国的顶级足球运动员，你想去皇家马德里。你想去巴塞罗那。你想去拜仁慕尼黑。你想去阿森纳。
Yet someone who wants to connect with an American audience might choose a different analogy, but you get the point. Early on in this whole adventure, Gad made a documentary for French TV about moving to the States. In one scene, the French Jerry Seinfeld is sitting at a restaurant with one of the few people who understands exactly how difficult it will be to make it in America-- the American Jerry Seinfeld. They're friends.
然而，一个想与美国观众建立联系的人可能会选择不同的类比，但你明白了。在整个冒险的早期，加德为法国电视台拍摄了一部关于搬到美国的纪录片。在其中一个场景中，法国的杰瑞·宋飞正坐在餐厅里，和少数几个确切知道在美国取得成功有多困难的人之一——美国杰瑞·宋飞在一起。他们是朋友。
Let me tell you. Let me explain this to you. The comedian-- the stand-up comedian-- was invented in America.
让我告诉你。让我跟你解释一下。喜剧演员——单口喜剧演员——是在美国发明的。
Yeah.
是的。
It was invented in America.
是在美国发明的。
So you're surprised that I came to America to do this?
所以你对我也来美国做这件事感到惊讶？
I get what you're doing. It's like, I want to go build a car, but I want to build it in Germany.
我明白你在做什么。这就像，我想去造一辆车，但我想要在德国造。
OK.
好的。
And people say, really? In Germany? Then I'm going to go to Italy, and I'm gonna open up a pasta factory. And then I'm going to go to France. I want to make wine.
然后人们会说，真的吗？在德国？然后我要去意大利，我要开一家意面工厂。然后我要去法国。我想酿酒。
OK.
好的。
All right? And then I'm going to England, and I'm going to write some plays.
好吗？然后我要去英国，我要写一些戏剧。
OK.
好的。
Right? And then I'm going to go to America, and I'm going to do stand-up comedy.
对吧？然后我要去美国，我要做单口喜剧。
Yeah, so--
是的，所以——
Those people are used to the best.
那些人习惯了最好的。
OK.
好的。
You with me?
你明白我的意思吗？
I'm with you.
我明白了。
So if it was me-- honestly, if it was me and I had what you had in France, I would just--
所以如果是我的话——老实说，如果是我的话，我有你在法国拥有的那些东西，我只会——
You would stay.
你会留下来。
I'm good. But I admire your ambition. I admire it.
我很满足。但我钦佩你的雄心壮志。我钦佩它。
This is-- yeah. I like to hear that.
这很好——是的。我喜欢听这个。
I admire that. Yes. Yes. You have to be comfortable that it's going to hurt.
我钦佩这一点。是的。是的。你必须习惯它会带来痛苦。
This isn't the first unlikely quest Gad's embarked on. He's one of the people who brought stand-up comedy to France. Amazingly, it didn't exist there at all until about 15 years ago. Gad says they had no comedy clubs. Before then, he was a kind of entertainer that doesn't really exist here. He did these theatrical one-man shows, playing all sorts of characters, singing songs. But at some point, he became obsessed with the American style of comedy and started addressing his audience directly, telling them jokes just like we do here in the States-- in other words, stand-up.
这不是加德踏上的第一次不太可能的冒险。他是把单口喜剧带到法国的人之一。令人惊讶的是，直到大约15年前，那里根本不存在这种表演。加德说他们没有喜剧俱乐部。在那之前，他是那种我们这里并不真正存在的艺人。他做那种戏剧性的一人秀，扮演各种角色，唱着歌。但在某个时候，他开始沉迷于美式喜剧风格，并开始直接面对观众，像我们这里在美国那样给他们讲笑话——换句话说，单口喜剧。
It was so new. People were like, oh, wow. What is this? He's talking to us. They were not used to it. No pigeon, no rope, no hats, no wigs.
太新了。人们就像，哦，哇。这是什么？他在跟我们说话。他们不习惯这样。没有鸽子，没有绳子，没有帽子，没有假发。
You're not being metaphorical. There were actual pigeons and ropes and wigs in your act before?
你不是在用比喻吧。你在表演之前真的有鸽子、绳子和假发？
No.
不。
You are being metaphorical?
你是在用比喻？
Yeah. It is just because this is how American comedians make fun of me sometimes. Like, oh, how is your show in France? Do you do mime and have like a pigeon and magic tricks? Because this is the stereotype. And if I want to talk about the stereotype we have on American comedians, I would say a guy standing up who doesn't move at all with a mic, a little depressed, and say jokes, jokes, jokes, jokes, jokes.
是的。这只是因为美国喜剧演员有时是这样取笑我的。比如，哦，你在法国的演出怎么样？你做哑剧，还有像鸽子和魔术吗？因为这是刻板印象。如果我想谈谈我们对美国喜剧演员的刻板印象，我会说是一个站在那里一动不动拿着麦克风的人，有点抑郁，然后讲笑话，笑话，笑话，笑话，笑话。
But his French act is still very different from an American stand-up act. In his hour-plus long French specials, he plays piano and guitar and beats on his guitar like a bongo. And there are special guests. It's a boogaloo of a production-- everything but the pigeons. He tells a couple stories about his kid. He's got two-- one with Grace Kelly's granddaughter. He does a lot of observational humor. But he's 10 times more physical in his French act. He's practically performing the scene.
但他的法语表演与美国单口表演仍然有很大不同。在他一小时以上的法语专场中，他弹钢琴和吉他，还像敲邦戈鼓一样拍打吉他。还有特别嘉宾。这是一个热闹的制作——除了鸽子，什么都有。他讲了几个关于他孩子的段子。他有两个——一个是跟格蕾丝·凯利的孙女生的。他做很多观察式幽默。但他法语表演中的肢体动作要多出10倍。他几乎是在现场表演那个场景。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[说法语]
He's saying on an airplane, when they hand out little towelettes that smell good, you're like, yeah! I'm going to live the moment. Then he sits in a chair and acts out the part of an ecstatic passenger.
他说在飞机上，当他们分发闻起来不错的湿巾时，你就像，耶！我要活在当下。然后他坐在椅子上，表现出一个狂喜乘客的样子。
[EXCITED SNIFFING]
[兴奋的嗅探声]
[MUTTERING]
[咕哝声]
[SINGING IN FRENCH]
[用法语唱歌]
So how do you translate that into American? Gad says you can't.
那么你如何把那个翻译成美式英语呢？加德说你不能。
I immediately, very quickly, realized that translating my French jokes into English was not the thing to do-- the good thing to do.
我很快，非常快地意识到，把我的法语笑话翻译成英语不是要做的事——不是正确要做的事。
Did you try that?
你试过吗？
I tried.
我试过。
And failed-- kind of spectacularly, in some cases. A lot of the stuff in his French act just doesn't travel well. Only a couple bits survived. He had to drop all the jokes about people freaking out when they meet him because he's so famous.
然后失败了——在某些情况下，相当壮观地失败了。他法语表演中的很多东西翻译过去效果不好。只有几个梗活了下来。他不得不放弃所有关于人们在见到他时因为他太出名而抓狂的笑话。
Then there's the stuff he had to drop because of the obvious cultural barriers, or because of the vagaries of either language. For instance, he had this joke. He's mortified talking about it now, but it was about a common expression in French. French people, when someone breaks into their house, they say, je me sens violee. I feel like I've been violated. Except the word "violee" in French also means rape.
然后还有一些他因为明显的文化障碍，或者因为两种语言的变幻莫测而不得不放弃的东西。例如，他有一个笑话。他现在谈论它觉得很尴尬，但这是关于法语中一个常见的表达。法国人在有人闯入他们家时会说，“je me sens violee”。我感觉我被侵犯了。除了“violee”这个词在法语中也意味着强奸。
But in French, it's not as shocking as rape. So I didn't know that. So what I said-- I said, you know what guys? We have an expression. When people get burglarized, they say, I felt I was raped. [GASP] And it was like terrible, like ice, like silence. And I was like, oh my god. What did I say? I should not say that.
但在法语中，它没有强奸那么令人震惊。所以我不知道。所以我说的——我说，你知道吗伙计们？我们有一个表达。当人们被入室盗窃时，他们会说，我感觉我被强奸了。[吸气声] 然后就像可怕，就像冰，就像沉默。我当时想，天哪。我说了什么？我不应该说那个。
Gad's next challenge, he had to recalibrate the pacing of his entire act. Turns out, comedy in France is like everything in France-- laid back, laissez-faire. They kind of ease into jokes the way they take a long time to eat dinner. He actually has a joke about that. Whereas in America--
加德的下一个挑战，他不得不重新校准他整场表演的节奏。事实证明，法国的喜剧就像法国的一切一样——轻松，自由放任。他们有点像吃晚餐那样慢慢地进入笑话。他实际上有一个关于这个的笑话。而美国——
The structure of the phrases are shorter and sharper-- sharper? So what I've been doing every day is cutting the fat. I remember, when I first started to do the clubs, I was-- oh my god. I had long setups.
短语的结构更短更尖锐——尖锐？所以我每天都在做的是剔除脂肪。我记得，当我刚开始在俱乐部演出时，我——天哪。我有很长的铺垫。
OK. So I-- yeah. I was walking, and I said, I'm going to go to that store, so I went to that store. And the guy came up to me and said-- oh, my god. And I was with some friends-- like good friends-- and they said, Gad, stop that. Just go right away. This guy in a store told me this. I thought he was-- boom, boom, bam, bheem. Punchline. That's it. Stop with the whole pigeon thing.
好的。所以我——是的。我走着，我说，我要去那家店，所以我去了那家店。然后那家伙走过来对我说——天哪。我和一些朋友——像好朋友——在一起，他们说，加德，停下。直接进入主题。这家店里的家伙告诉了我这个。我以为他是——砰，砰，砰，砰，砰。包袱。就这样。别再提什么鸽子的事了。
The hardest part of this whole endeavor is maybe what you'd guess-- the language. Gad's made a lot of progress since learning how to say Brian is in the kitchen as a kid. But after a few hours of speaking English, even just to us, Gad's exhausted. He says his brain turns to mush, and he just wants to speak French.
这整个努力中最困难的部分可能是你所猜测的那样——语言。自从小时候学会说“布莱恩在厨房里”以来，加德取得了很大进步。但在说了几个小时英语后，即使只是跟我们说话，加德也精疲力竭了。他说他的大脑变成了浆糊，他只想说法语。
And a huge part of Gad's quest to become an American comedian is hard core language training. So much of comedy is about timing. If you're off by a beat or a syllable, you murder the joke. The joke is dead. So Gad's working with a language coach several times a week, dissecting his jokes, phrase by phrase, and syllable by syllable.
而加德成为美国喜剧演员的整个探索中，很大一部分是硬核语言训练。喜剧中很大一部分是关于时机的。如果你偏离了一个节拍或一个音节，你就杀死了这个笑话。这个笑话就死了。所以加德每周几次与语言教练一起工作，逐句逐句，逐音节逐音节地剖析他的笑话。
Last night I did the American dream thing.
昨晚我做了美国梦的那段。
Yep.
耶。
And it was very hard. They didn't get it.
非常难。他们没听懂。
We sat in on Gad's session with his tutor, Julia Lenardon, in Gad's crash pad, i.e., a massive luxury apartment in Tribeca.
我们旁听了加德在加德临时住所——即翠贝卡区一套巨大的豪华公寓里——与他的导师朱莉娅·莱纳登的课程。
Why? Because it's worked before. What happened?
为什么？因为以前管用。发生了什么？
Because it's the, I've wondered, and I was wondering, and I've always wondered. And my father used to take us to the ocean, or took us to the ocean. It's always-- I'm always confused.
因为是那个，“我一直在想”，和“我当时在想”，和“我一直都在想”。还有我父亲过去带我们去海边，或者是带我们去海边。总是——我总是很困惑。
This joke is about how his father used to take him to the beach, point at the ocean, and tell Gad that, if you sail for days and nights, you will reach America. Gad wondered if any American father was standing on the shore pointing towards Morocco, saying the same thing.
这个笑话是关于他父亲过去常带他去海滩，指着大海，告诉加德，如果你航行几天几夜，你就会到达美国。加德想知道是否有美国父亲站在岸边指着摩洛哥，说着同样的话。
So he did it several times, or he did it once? That's what I need.
所以他做了几次，还是他做了一次？这就是我需要的。
Every time we would go to the beach he would stand in front of the ocean and say this crazy thing.
每次我们去海滩，他都会站在大海前说这种疯狂的话。
Then my father would take me.
然后我父亲会带我。
Yeah. My father would take me.
是的。我父亲会带我。
As opposed to--
而不是——
Maybe that's why, I don't know, they don't get it. I like it. It's not a crazy joke, but it's a poetic image. I always wondered if, on the other side of the ocean, there was an American father--
也许这就是为什么，我不知道，他们没听懂。我喜欢它。这不是一个疯狂的笑话，但它是一个诗意的形象。我一直想知道，在海洋的另一边，是否有一个美国父亲——
Yeah. You see, that's the thing. An American father. That's the thing is you've got your keyword that you have to lift with pitch. And then you have to drop the next word because that's how we hear the contrast. The American father.
是的。你看，这就是关键。一个美国父亲。关键是你有一个关键词，你必须用音高来强调它。然后你必须降低下一个词，因为那就是我们如何听到对比的方式。美国父亲。
An American father.
一个美国父亲。
I'm not sure that on the other side of the ocean there was an American father [INAUDIBLE].
我不确定在海洋的另一边是否有一个美国父亲[听不清]。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
For a while, Gad had this other joke that just wasn't working till Julia told Gad to say "vay-KAY-shun" instead of "VAY-kay-shun." If that doesn't work, she said, you can fire me. It worked. When you know how hard it is for him, watching him do an hour set in English looks like an Olympic feat. But of course, that's not how these things are scored.
有一段时间，加德有另一个笑话一直没效果，直到朱莉娅告诉加德说“vay-KAY-shun”而不是“VAY-kay-shun”。如果那不管用，她说，你可以开除我。管用了。当你了解对他来说有多难时，看他用英语做一小时的演出就像是一项奥林匹克成就。但当然，评分标准不是这样的。
Gad's about a year into his new American life. And to be clear, because of his fame elsewhere and his connections, Gad's had about every conceivable unfair advantage a, quote, "fledgling comedian in America" could ask for. That show you heard at Joe's Pub was actually opening night of a six-month residency, three shows a week. No rookie comedian in New York gets that. They knew he could pack the room with French ex-pats. Gad's been on The Daily Show , The Nightly Show , Late Night with Seth Meyers . He did a set on Conan .
加德在他的美国新生活中大约过了一年。需要明确的是，因为他在其他地方的知名度和他人脉，加德拥有了几乎所有你所说的“美国新晋喜剧演员”所能要求的不公平优势。你在乔酒吧听到的那场演出实际上是六个月驻场表演的开幕之夜，每周三场演出。纽约没有新秀喜剧演员能得到那个。他们知道他能用法国外籍人士填满房间。加德上过《每日秀》、《夜间秀》、大卫·莱特曼的《深夜秀》。他在《柯南秀》上做了一段表演。
And he's getting better. His set got tighter during his residency at Joe's Pub. And he might still have the occasional language misstep, but it's happening later in the show. His English is improving. And he just knows his way around the act now. When it works, Gad says, it means more to him than performing for his French fans who've seen his DVDs and know every joke and laugh at everything.
而且他越来越好了。他在乔酒吧驻场期间，他的段子变得更紧凑了。他可能偶尔还会有语言失误，但那是发生在演出后期。他的英语在进步。而且他现在知道怎么处理这场表演了。加德说，当它奏效时，这对他来说比为那些看过他DVD、知道每一个笑话并对一切都笑的法国粉丝表演更有意义。
When American audience laugh at my joke, I mean, I feel I'm just, oh, I'm funny. I'm a funny man. I'm not that guy. And even in my everyday life, if I go to a store and I make someone laugh, like at the grocery store, I'm so happy because I'm like, oh, she doesn't know that I'm famous in France, and she just laughed so hard at my joke. I made a joke about, I don't know, cheese or whatever, and I asked her a question and I made this little face, and she was laughing-- really laughing-- and I'm like, oh, I'm a funny man. I'm a funny man.
当美国观众对我的笑话发笑时，我的意思是，我感觉我只是，哦，我很幽默。我是个幽默的人。我不是那个人。即使在我的日常生活中，如果我去商店，我让某人笑，比如在杂货店，我太开心了，因为我心想，哦，她不知道我在法国很有名，她只是被我的笑话逗笑了。我讲了一个关于，我不知道，奶酪还是什么的笑话，我问了她一个问题，我做了这个小表情，她就在笑——真正地在笑——我心想，哦，我真是个幽默的人。我真是个幽默的人。
I love to be anonymous. I love-- I love it. And I hope it's not going to stay like this forever. [LAUGHS]
我喜欢默默无闻。我喜欢——我喜欢它。我希望它不会永远保持这样。[笑声]
But does he really have a shot at becoming a name here in the US? To answer that, I turned to people who'd know-- some American comedy headliners. I talked to Colin Quinn, Ali Wong, Ron Funches, and Jeff Garlin. All of them watched the same video of a 15-minute set Gad did at the Comedy Cellar back in June. And they all agreed he's a pro. He could totally have a career here. But can he be great? They all said he's not there yet, and they were unanimous on what he needed to do next. There is one specific hole in his act all four pointed to. Here's Colin Quinn.
但他真的有希望在美国成为大人物吗？为了回答这个问题，我转向了那些会知道的人——一些美国喜剧头牌。我跟科林·奎因、黄艾丽、罗恩·芬奇斯和杰夫·加林聊过。他们都看了加德六月份在喜剧地窖做的15分钟表演的视频。他们都同意他是个专业人士。他完全可以在这里有事业。但他能成为伟大的人吗？他们都说他还没到那一步，而且他们一致认为他接下来需要做什么。他们四个人都指出了他表演中有一个具体的漏洞。这是科林·奎因。
Talking about his perceptions of America. All that stuff is great. Love it, love it, love it-- for 20 minutes. Then I want to hear about his life, and I want to hear about France or Morocco. He's had this fascinating life. Let's [BLEEP] hear about it.
谈论他对美国的看法。所有这些东西都很棒。喜欢它，喜欢它，喜欢它——持续20分钟。然后我想听听他的生活，我想听听法国或摩洛哥的故事。他有过这种迷人的生活。让我们他妈的听听它。
The whole point of going to see a comedian is you want to see something that other comedians don't do. What about your country? I'm interested. It's all relatable. It's emotions, you know what I mean? My favorite expression-- now I get to use my favorite expression, which I'm always looking for an excuse. In the specific is the universal.
去看喜剧演员的全部意义在于你想看到其他喜剧演员不做的事情。你的国家呢？我很感兴趣。这都是可关联的。都是情感，你明白我的意思吗？我最喜欢的表达——现在我有机会使用我最喜欢的表达，我一直在找借口。在具体中就是普遍。
What would he have to do to go from this level that he's at right now to being great?
他需要做什么才能从现在的水平达到伟大？
He'd have to listen to what I just said.
他得听听我刚才说的。
Being personal-- that's where American comedy's at right now. Ali Wong said something similar after she watched the video.
变得个人化——这就是美国喜剧现在的方向。黄艾丽在看了视频后也说了类似的话。
It was so interesting because you can tell that he's a really seasoned performer, and he's very comfortable on stage.
这太有趣了，因为你可以看出他是一个非常老练的表演者，而且他在舞台上非常自在。
But she said that, like a lot of rookie comedians in New York, the topics he gravitates toward are a little too generic.
但她说，像纽约的许多新晋喜剧演员一样，他倾向的主题有点太普通了。
You know, how hard it is to get an apartment, why women always want to commit, Indian cab drivers talk a lot on their phone. For me, when you're a headliner, those are people who kind of give a lot of their essence on stage. Like, I would love to know why the Jerry Seinfeld of France would want to do stand-up in America all of a sudden?
你知道，租公寓有多难，为什么女人总是想承诺，印度出租车司机一直在电话里聊天。对我来说，当你是一名头牌时，那些人在舞台上给予了很多他们的本质。比如，我很想知道为什么法国的杰瑞·宋飞会突然想在美国做单口喜剧？
Ron Funches agreed with Ali that the most obvious thing for Gad to talk about is one of the topics he thought he had to avoid on stage-- his fame.
罗恩·芬奇斯和艾丽一样同意，关于加德最明显的话题是他认为自己必须在舞台上避免的话题之一——他的名气。
This-- what's going on now, his fear of being like, oh, I'm a big deal in France, and now I'm in America, and I'm not that big of a deal. Tell me what that's about. Tell me how that feels. That's probably terrifying and also very brave of you to step out of your comfort zone. Tell me about that. Tell me what you think is funny about that. That would be very interesting to me.
这——现在发生的事，他害怕被认为，哦，我在法国是个大人物，现在我在美国，我不是什么大人物。告诉我那是关于什么的。告诉我那是什么感觉。那可能很可怕，但也非常勇敢，因为你走出了舒适区。告诉我那些。告诉我你觉得其中哪些地方好笑。那对我来说会非常有趣。
I think it's a good point.
我觉得这是个好观点。
Again, here's Gad. We played him all the feedback, and he was a good sport about it, and he thought it was good advice. He really liked Ron's idea for how to talk about his fame.
再说一次，加德。我们把所有的反馈都放给他听，他对此很有体育精神，而且他认为这是很好的建议。他真的很喜欢罗恩关于如何谈论他名气的点子。
His point of view is interesting. So maybe I should explain-- just tell them, guys, it's a new life, being famous somewhere and maybe sometimes I'm walking down the street in New York City and I don't get bothered. But it's also bizarre, you know? I want to go to some people and say, do you want a photo or something?
他的观点很有趣。所以也许我应该解释——只是告诉他们，伙计们，这是新生活，在某处出名，也许有时我在纽约街头走，没人烦我。但这也是怪诞的，你知道吗？我想去找些人说，你们想要合影吗？
[LAUGHS] Yeah. Bother me.
[笑声] 是的。烦我吧。
Do you want a photo of us? No. That would be good, no?
你想要跟我合影吗？不。因为我在法国很有名。是的，但那是在法国。那很有趣。我应该那样做。
That's good.
那很好。
Do you want a picture with me? No. Because I'm famous in France. Yeah, but that's in France. That's funny. I should do that.
你想要跟我拍张照片吗？不。因为我在法国很有名。是的，但那是在法国。那很有趣。我应该那样做。
But the most pointed criticism was from Jeff Garlin. You might recognize Jeff as Larry David's sidekick/manager on Curb Your Enthusiasm , but he's got 30 years in stand-up. He worked with Jon Stewart and Denis Leary on their stand-up specials, and he's a comic's comic. We weren't talking for very long before he just cut to the chase.
但最尖锐的批评来自杰夫·加林。你可能认出杰夫是《抑制热情》里拉里·戴维的搭档/经理，但他有30年的单口喜剧经验。他在乔恩·斯图尔特和丹尼斯·利里的单口专场里跟他们合作过，他是喜剧演员中的喜剧演员。我们没聊多久，他就直接切入重点。
He does not make me laugh.
他没让我笑。
Huh.
呵。
Yes. But I find him unbelievably charming. I think he's charismatic. He's charming. I could see him becoming very successful here. The audience was under his spell. He has a spell. There's a craft to stand-up comedy as well as an art, and he is a master at the craft. I don't look at him as much of an artist.
是的。但我发现他难以置信地迷人。我觉得他很有魅力。他很迷人。我能看到他在这里变得非常成功。观众都在他的魔咒之下。他有一种魔力。单口喜剧既有艺术也有工艺，而他是工艺大师。我对他作为艺术家的看法没那么多。
Jeff said to be an artist, he'd have to be more passionate about the stuff he's talking about. It doesn't matter what it is.
杰夫说要成为艺术家，他必须对他谈论的东西更充满激情。那是什么东西并不重要。
Just tell me what you care about. He doesn't care about Starbucks on every corner. That's a bunch of crap. And let me tell you, if he's not bored doing that every night, there's something wrong with him because I'd want to kill myself. What do you care about, Gad? That's what I'm saying. What do you care about?
只要告诉我你在乎什么。他根本不在乎每个角落的星巴克。那是一堆废话。让我告诉你，如果他每晚做那个不觉得无聊，那他肯定有什么毛病，因为我要是那样我会想自杀。你在乎什么，加德？这就是我在说的。你在乎什么？
Interesting. Wow. Yeah, yeah. Wow. Now that I-- the English is OK, I should maybe be more fragile, even though it's in English, and maybe trust what I think, trust what I feel. Wow. Now it's getting really interesting.
有趣。哇。是的，是的。哇。现在——英语还可以，我也许应该更脆弱一点，即使是在英语中，也许相信我的想法，相信我的感觉。哇。现在变得真有趣。
Gad couldn't stop thinking about this. 20 minutes later, he just interrupted Sean mid-sentence to come back to it.
加德无法停止思考这一点。20分钟后，他只是打断了肖恩的话，回到这个话题。
So I'm just wondering how you see yourself having--
所以我只是在想你是怎么看待你自己拥有——
Now let me tell you something.
现在让我告诉你一件事。
Yes.
是的。
We had those five minutes of their critiques and the thinking, and now my brain is already working on the new material.
我们有了那五分钟的批评和思考，现在我的大脑已经在研究新素材了。
Wow.
哇。
It's a little revolution today for me. So it's really interesting. It's a shock, but it's in a good way.
对我来说今天是一场小革命。所以这真的很有趣。这是一个冲击，但是以好的方式。
What are you thinking about?
你在想什么？
I'm thinking that, when I will go to clubs, I really want to go there. I really want to try to talk more about my roots, Morocco, friends, and not only comparing-- not only saying, oh, you guys do this? We do that. You guys do this? We do that. Man, that's really, really a good shock that you gave me today.
我在想，当我以后去俱乐部时，我真的想去那里。我真的想尝试多谈谈我的根源，摩洛哥，朋友，而不只是比较——不只是说，哦，你们这样做？我们做那样。你们这样做？我们做那样。伙计，那真是，真是你今天给我的一个好的冲击。
There will be a before and after today. Really. What do you care about? I remember, what do you care about? What does he care about? I care about people who say what does he care about. Merci.
今天之后会有之前和之后。真的。你在乎什么？我记得，你在乎什么？他在乎什么？我在乎那些问他“他在乎什么”的人。谢谢。
I saw Gad at the Comedy Cellar one more time after that interview, two weeks ago. He hadn't changed up his set much. He wasn't getting into the personal stuff yet. I asked him why, and he said, revolutions don't happen overnight.
那次采访后两周，我又在喜剧地窖见过加德一次。他并没有做太多改动。他还没开始接触个人化素材。我问他为什么，他说，革命不是一夜之间发生的。
The comedians I talked to were adamant. For Gad to come up with the kind of material he's going to need to be great in America-- the personal stuff, the stuff he really cares about-- the only way to develop that is to do painful sets on stage where he tries out all kinds of stuff and lets himself bomb. In France, he doesn't do that. And Gad told me it goes against all his instincts-- against 22 years of training-- but he's going to have to override that instinct. He's going to have to embrace bombing, learn to fail at comedy at a whole new level, if he's going to succeed here. It's a concept that's totally foreign to him.
我聊过的那些喜剧演员很坚定。为了让加德想出他要在美国变得伟大所需要的素材——个人化的东西，他真正关心的东西——发展的唯一途径是在舞台上进行痛苦的演出，尝试各种东西并让自己搞砸。在法国，他不那么做。加德告诉我，这违反了他所有的直觉——违反了22年的训练——但他必须覆盖那种直觉。他必须拥抱搞砸，学习在单口喜剧上以全新的水平失败，如果他想在这里成功的话。这对他来说是个完全陌生的概念。
Zack McDermott in New York.
扎克·麦克德莫特在纽约。
Gad Elmaleh is about to embark on a European tour, performing in French-- you know, for a change. American shows resume in the new year. We have some clips of him performing in English on our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. In February, he'll be in Carnegie Hall.
加德·艾尔马莱即将开始欧洲巡演，表演法语——你知道，换换口味。美国演出将在新的一年恢复。我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org上有他用英语表演的片段。二月份，他将在卡内基音乐厅演出。
[MUSIC - "FAMOUS IN FRANCE" BY JOHN MCDERMOTT AND MICHAEL P. SMITH]
[音乐 - 约翰·麦克德莫特和迈克尔·P·史密斯的《FAMOUS IN FRANCE》]
Coming up, a little dog who lives in an apartment and whose favorite toy is called a Giggle Ball goes tete-a-tete with the wily creatures that brought us the bubonic plague. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
即将到来，一只住在公寓里、最喜欢的玩具叫“咯咯球”的小狗，与给我们带来黑死病的狡猾生物进行一对一的较量。那是在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Becoming a Badger, stories of people trying to become something totally foreign, trying to see the world through new eyes.
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，“成为一只獾”，关于人们试图成为完全陌生事物的故事，试图通过新的眼睛看世界。
[MUSIC - "THE 5TH QUARTER" BY THE MADHATTERS]
[音乐 - 疯帽子乐队的《THE 5TH QUARTER》]
Those are the MadHatters from Madison, Wisconsin, singing a fight song from the University of Wisconsin, whose football team, of course, is the Badgers. And with that, we have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Curious Incident of the Dog in the Nighttime.
那是来自威斯康星州麦迪逊的疯帽子乐队，在唱威斯康星大学的战斗歌，威斯康星大学的足球队，当然就是獾队。随着那个，我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“狗在夜间的离奇事件”。
So we heard at the beginning of our show about an Oxford scholar who was trying to understand what it's like to be an animal. Now, in this act, we hear about an animal trying to understand what it's like to be an animal.
所以我们在节目开头听到了一个关于牛津学者试图理解成为动物是什么感觉。现在，在这一幕中，我们听到关于一个动物试图理解成为动物是什么感觉。
I sometimes have this thought about my own dog, which is his feet never touch the earth. Like, they never touch grass and dirt. He lives in a city. He lives on sidewalk and in a tiny apartment 40 feet above the ground. Our producers Zoe Chace and Emmanuel Dzotsi have this story of a dog-- an urban dog-- getting more in touch with the doggy parts of himself.
我有时对自己狗有这样一个想法，就是他的脚从不触及大地。就像，它们从不碰草和泥土。他住在城市里。他住在人行道上，住在离地面40英尺高的一间微小的公寓里。我们的制作人佐伊·蔡斯和伊曼纽尔·佐齐有这样一个关于一只狗的故事——一只城市狗——更多地接触他自己身上狗的部分。
When we set out to do this story, Ira was like, you've got to put a mic on our main character. His name is Ray Ray.
当我们着手做这个故事时，艾拉说，你得给我们的主角戴上麦克风。他的名字是雷雷。
Ray Ray is a dog-- a terrier. We attached a tiny microphone to his collar.
雷雷是一只狗——梗犬。我们在他的项圈上装了一个微小的麦克风。
Ray Ray, you're going to be my first radio dog. Ray, say something.
雷雷，你要成为我的第一只无线电狗。雷，说点什么。
A ball is thrown down the hallway. This is what it's like to be Ray Ray.
一个球被扔进走廊。这就是成为雷雷的感觉。
[SCAMPERING]
[小跑声]
Some mix of eternal optimism and desperation to catch the thing that is getting away from you.
某种永恒的乐观和捕获正在逃离你的东西的绝望的混合体。
[SCAMPERING]
[小跑声]
The owner of the dog in question is Judy.
这只狗的主人是朱迪。
Sit. No more. We have to save it for later.
坐。别动。我们得留着以后用。
She's the kind of old-school New Yorker that you meet less and less. She was born on the Lower East Side, grew up in Queens, doesn't have a car, doesn't really leave the city. And she's lived in the same tiny, two-room apartment for 30 years. She's a dog person. She lives with this big, quiet greyhound and Ray Ray, the hyper little terrier. He's a rescue. Before that--
她是那种你越来越少见的旧派纽约人。她出生在下东区，在皇后区长大，没有车，也不怎么离开城市。她在那间微小的两居室公寓里住了30年。她是个爱狗的人。她和这只大而安静的灰狗以及雷雷，那只超级活跃的小梗犬住在一起。他是一只救援犬。在那之前——
I think he was in a home in New Jersey because he had no street skills at all. And his pads-- like he had never walked on concrete. His pads were like pink baby pads.
我想他是在新泽西的一个收容所里，因为他根本没有任何街道技能。他的脚垫——就像他从没在混凝土上走过。他的脚垫就像粉红色的婴儿脚垫。
Judy trains dogs. She's a dog walker and dog sitter. And not long after she got Ray, she noticed he kind of goes nuts around rats, which, in New York, comes up all the time. Not long ago, he saw a rat just across from the Epiphany Church on 22nd Street, started lunging and pulling at the leash.
朱迪训练狗。她是遛狗员和寄养员。得到雷后不久，她注意到他在老鼠周围会有点发疯，这在纽约一直是个问题。不久前，他看到一只老鼠就在第22街的顿悟教堂对面，开始猛冲并拉扯皮带。
One darted out, and he went to nail it. Yeah. It was so fast that I'm glad that I had a good hold on the leash because he would've yanked the leash right out of my hand.
一只冲出来，他就要去抓它。是的。它太快了，我很高兴我紧紧抓着皮带，否则他会直接把它从我手里扯走。
Some dogs are bred to swim. Some are bred to herd sheep or rescue people from the snow. Terriers are bred to hunt rats. They did this in factories and farms in England 200 years ago. They're bred small so they can chase rats into holes.
有些狗是为了游泳而繁育的。有些是为了赶羊或从雪中营救人们而繁育的。梗犬是为了捕鼠而繁育的。它们200年前在英国的工厂和农场里做这个。它们被繁育得很小，这样它们可以追赶老鼠进洞。
Recently, Judy read on Facebook about this group, The Ryders Alley Trencher-Fed Society, acronym RATS. It's a club of dog owners, mostly terriers. On Friday nights, half a dozen of them take their dogs out onto the streets of New York so their terriers can get a chance to really be terriers, do what they're bred for-- hunt for rats.
最近，朱迪在Facebook上读到了关于这个团体，莱德胡同挖掘喂养协会，缩写RATS。这是一个狗主人俱乐部，大部分是梗犬。周五晚上，半打人带着他们的狗上纽约街头，这样他们的梗犬就有机会真正成为梗犬，做它们为之繁育的事——捕鼠。
On Facebook, Judy saw picture after picture of dogs chasing rats. Grimy. Garbage strewn around the street. Not Judy's scene. But Judy is exceptionally good, I think, at seeing from a dog's perspective. She wants what he wants. And he clearly wants rats.
在Facebook上，朱迪看到一张接一张狗追老鼠的照片。肮脏。垃圾散落在街上。不是朱迪的场景。但我认为，朱迪特别擅长从狗的角度观察。她想要他想要的。而且他显然想要老鼠。
I want to do this with him. I want him to experience a piece of himself that he doesn't get to experience.
我想跟他一起做这个。我希望他体验他没机会体验的他自己的一部分。
Their first hunt is tonight in just a couple hours. The terrier club made clear this would be an audition. Ray Ray would be trying out. Some terriers still have the instinct. You don't have to train them. They're just rat-killing machines. But other terriers aren't like that. Ray's a bit of a mutt-- a terrier mix. Still, Judy's confident.
他们的第一次狩猎是在今晚几个小时后。梗犬俱乐部明确表示这将是一次试演。雷雷将参加试演。有些梗犬仍然有本能。你不需要训练它们。它们只是捕鼠机器。但其他梗犬不是那样的。雷是有点杂种——梗犬混血。尽管如此，朱迪很自信。
He's got a very high prey drive.
他有非常高的猎物动力。
He has a very high what?
他有什么非常高的？
Prey drive. P-R-E-Y drive. It's prey. There's no doubt in my mind that he will do this. I know he's going to go crazy.
猎物动力。猎物。我毫无疑问他会做这个。我知道他会发疯的。
At this moment, Ray was attacking a small, blue teddy bear.
此时，雷正在攻击一只蓝色的小泰迪熊。
Watching him do, right now, to some little teddy bear what he's going to do to this rat--
看着他现在对那只小泰迪熊所做的，就是他要对那只老鼠做的事情——
Yeah. That's what he does. They shred. Are you a shredder?
是的。那就是他做的。它们撕碎。你是撕碎者吗？
That's the level of adversary Ray Ray's had to deal with his whole life thus far-- inanimate, gut full of fluff, no guile, no teeth. I wondered how Ray would do.
这就是雷雷至今为止一生不得不面对的对手的水平——无生命的，肚子里塞满绒毛，没有诡计，没有牙齿。我想知道雷会表现得怎么样。
Later that same night, 10:00 PM. Grand and Henry Streets. We're just outside a dark playground. It's 90 degrees. Sweaty. It smells like pee and hot garbage.
那天晚上晚些时候，晚上10点。格兰德街和亨利街。我们就在一个黑暗的操场外面。有90度。汗流浃背。闻起来有尿和热垃圾的味道。
Ray, why are you crying so much? Because he's anxious?
雷，你为什么叫得这么多？因为他焦虑吗？
When we catch up with the Ryder Trencher-Fed Society, it's a small group-- two men, a lady, three terriers. They look impatient and serious. Richard is the leader. He's an older guy wearing a baseball cap and Kevlar gloves. Ray Ray immediately starts to bark like crazy at the other terriers.
当我们赶上莱德胡同挖掘喂养协会时，这是一个小团体——两个男人，一位女士，三只梗犬。他们看起来不耐烦且严肃。理查德是领队。他是个戴着棒球帽和凯夫拉手套的老家伙。雷雷立刻开始对着其他梗犬疯狂地叫。
[BARKING]
[吠叫声]
Ray Ray's making a terrible first impression. One of the other terrier owners shakes his head, and he says he's not sure this is going to work out.
雷雷留下了糟糕的第一印象。另一位梗犬主人摇摇头，他说他不确定这能不能成。
Look at me. Look at me. Ray, look.
看着我。看着我。雷，看。
Judy finally gets Ray quieted down, and Richard launches into a sort of lecture to Judy, explaining what Ray Ray is going to have to do.
朱迪终于让雷安静下来，理查德开始对朱迪进行某种讲座，解释雷雷将不得不做什么。
What we're looking for is, primarily, the dog that can hunt by scent here in the city, because the rats are there. You can't see them for the most part.
我们寻找的，主要是能在城里用嗅觉狩猎的狗，因为老鼠就在那里。大部分时间你看不见它们。
Richard is very serious about this, runs it like a British fox hunt, carries a cane, let's out the occasional--
理查德对此非常严肃，把它当成英国猎狐活动来跑，拿着手杖，偶尔发出——
Whoa! Tally-ho.
哇！看哪！
And they have battle plans. There's specific jobs. Some dogs are flushers. The flushers find the rats and chase them out of wherever they're hiding. And there are catchers. The catchers stand just a little ways off, waiting for a rat to come their way. And when the rat comes, the catcher bites.
他们有战斗计划。有具体工作。有些狗是冲刷者。冲刷者找到老鼠并将它们从它们藏身的地方赶出来。还有捕获者。捕获者站在不远处，等待老鼠跑向它们。当老鼠过来时，捕获者就咬。
Paco is one of the catch dogs. His owner lays out the strategy.
帕科是捕获犬之一。它的主人布置了策略。
What's his way in?
它的方法是什么？
He weighs in at 32 pounds.
他重32磅。
No, sorry. What's his way in when he's going to kill the rats? Like what's his method?
不，抱歉。当他要杀老鼠时，他的方法是什么？就像他的方法是什么？
Teeth. He'll grab 'em, shake 'em, crush 'em.
牙齿。他会抓住它们，摇晃它们，压碎它们。
Richard, the leader, says showtime, and we're off. The hunt has begun.
领队理查德说是时候了，我们出发了。狩猎开始了。
Come here. Catcher.
来这里。捕获者。
A warning to listeners. We told you the dogs are out here killing rats, so be aware. This gets intense. The 10 of us-- six people, four dogs-- slowly head down Broome Street. And just like in those movie scenes where the special ops team makes its way into enemy territory, it is weirdly quiet. The dogs are cautious. They sniff at garbage bags, dumpsters. Then--
给听众的一个警告。我们告诉过你们狗在这里杀老鼠，所以要注意。这变得紧张起来。我们10个人——6个人，4只狗——慢慢地沿着布鲁姆街走。就像电影场景中特种作战部队进入敌方领土一样，这里怪异地安静。狗很谨慎。它们嗅着垃圾袋、垃圾箱。然后——
Whoa! Whoa!
哇！哇！
Agh!
啊！
That's me screaming. Two rats just ran out onto the sidewalk.
那是我的尖叫。两只老鼠刚跑到人行道上。
Get 'em, Ray. Get 'em! Get 'em!
去抓它们，雷。去！去！
The dogs chase the rats, except for Ray, who just zigzags up and down the sidewalk, excited but confused. The rats sprint in front of us, and then they're gone. Richard's standing by a big SUV.
狗追老鼠，除了雷，他只是在人行道上来回跑，兴奋但困惑。老鼠在我们面前冲刺，然后它们不见了。理查德站在一辆大SUV旁边。
So where did all the rats go?
那么所有的老鼠都去哪了？
Into the cars. There's two rats in here.
进车里了。这里有两只老鼠。
What do you mean? You think the rats are inside this, like, Escalade?
你什么意思？你觉得老鼠在这辆，比如，凯雷德里？
No, they're up in the undercarriage, around the axle, around the motorhead.
不，它们在底盘上，绕着车轴，绕着发动机头。
Ugh. Doesn't that freak you out?
呃。那不会让你发疯吗？
Not particularly.
并不是特别。
Little Ray shuffles along a fence with Judy right behind him.
小雷拖着步子沿着围栏走，朱迪就在他后面。
Do you feel worried, like he doesn't have the hunter instinct?
你觉得担心吗，觉得他没有狩猎本能？
No. I know he does. It's just this is his first time, so he's leaving his mark everywhere. And I think that's a poop that I have to clean up. [LAUGHS]
不。我知道他有。只是这是他第一次，所以他到处留下记号。我想那是我得清理的大便。[笑声]
Come. Let's go.
来。我们走。
Next stop, a corner store with five huge garbage bags out front. Richard says this is basically a sure thing. There are always rats in garbage bags outside delis. The dogs start sniffing at it.
下一站，一家转角商店，门外有五个巨大的垃圾袋。理查德说这基本上是确定的。熟食店外面的垃圾袋里总是有老鼠。狗开始嗅它。
What is that? What is that? Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
那是什么？那是什么？啊，啊，啊，啊，啊。
There he goes.
他去了。
A couple rats flee the garbage pile and make a dash for the sewer. The dogs just missed them. Ray's running circles, basically, around the garbage bags. He's like the hype man for the other dogs. He's enthusiastic. Richard, our leader, is not impressed.
几只老鼠从垃圾堆逃走，冲向排水沟。狗正好错过了它们。雷在跑圈，基本上是绕着垃圾袋。他就像其他狗的炒作人。他很热情。我们的领队理查德没有留下深刻印象。
What?
什么？
He's getting into it.
他进去了。
Yeah, but I want him to stop going bat [BLEEP] and start hunting.
是的，但我希望他别再发疯，而是开始狩猎。
A guy walks out of the deli. His name is Jonathan Rivera. He lives in the neighborhood. He sees the commotion, and he comes over.
一个人从熟食店走出来。他的名字是乔纳森·里维拉。他住在附近。他看到了骚动，他过来了。
Do--
你——
Get 'em!
去！
Do you know what these guys are doing?
你知道这些人在做什么吗？
Yes. I've seen them many years before, and I appreciate what they're doing. The guys are awesome. All these [BLEEP] rodents and rats are manifesting. I've never seen no one in the whole entire New York City state--
是的。我多年前见过他们，我赞赏他们正在做的事。这些家伙太棒了。所有这些他妈的啮齿动物和老鼠都在显现。我从来没在整个纽约州见过任何人——
[BANGING]
[砰砰声]
--do something like this.
——做这样的事情。
Agh! They did [INAUDIBLE].
啊！他们做了[听不清]。
Yes! We got one! Killer, kill!
是的！我们抓到一个！杀手，杀！
One of the dogs had dived under a car and come out with a rat in his mouth.
其中一只狗钻到车下，嘴里叼着一只老鼠出来了。
What dog is that? What's his name? Hold on. Your dog's name's what?
那是什么狗？他叫什么名字？等一下。你的狗叫什么？
Tanner.
坦纳。
Tanner? Tanner just kicked ass right now, and got his kill on Broome Street. 157, between 154 Broome Street. Got his kill. And he is the MVP for the night. Tanner, 1-plus. The other dogs, zero. Hunger Games. Let's go.
坦纳？坦纳刚才踢了屁股，在布鲁姆街抓到了他的猎物。布鲁姆街154号到157号之间。抓到了他的猎物。他是今晚的MVP。坦纳，加一。其他狗，零。饥饿游戏。走吧。
Jonathan whips out his phone, takes a selfie with the dead rat, and puts it up on Snapchat.
乔纳森掏出他的手机，跟死老鼠拍了张自拍，把它发到了Snapchat上。
Catcher is carrying around a dead rat.
捕获者正带着一只死老鼠到处走。
Richard holds the rat up to Ray to get some sort of reaction, but Ray Ray just looks at it. Judy's lowering expectations.
理查德把老鼠举到雷面前想要得到某种反应，但雷雷只是看着它。朱迪在降低预期。
I don't think he's going to get one tonight. I think he's too much of a newbie.
我不觉得他今晚会抓到一只。我觉得他还是个新手。
Tanner is the oldest, blindest, deafest dog here. He just killed a rat. Paco just got one, too, but Ray Ray's score is still at zero. Though, I think that doesn't really capture the situation, because, obviously, you know who's really winning? The rats. Richard ran the numbers for us.
坦纳是这里最老、最瞎、最聋的狗。他刚刚杀了一只老鼠。帕科也抓到了一只，但雷雷的分数仍然是零。尽管，我觉得那并没有真正捕捉到情况，因为，显然，你知道谁才是真正的赢家？老鼠。理查德为我们算了一下数据。
A dog comes in season and is breedable once every six to nine months. A rat comes in season and is breedable every three days.
一只狗在发情期，每六到九个月可以繁育一次。一只老鼠在发情期，每三天可以繁育一次。
Ha! That's upsetting.
哈！那太让人心烦了。
The gestation period is 21 to 23 days. The average litter is 10 to 12. Now, you want to do a little bit of the math, you start with one pair of rats today, 365 days from now you have 24,000 rats. Maybe the most intelligent thing that I've ever heard was somebody said that, in New York City, you're never more than 30 feet from a rat.
妊娠期是21到23天。平均一窝是10到12只。现在，你想要算一点数学，你今天从一对老鼠开始，365天后你有24000只老鼠。也许我听过的最聪明的事情是有人说，在纽约市，你离老鼠从来不会超过30英尺。
One estimate says there are something like 2 million rats in New York City. It's taken us an hour to kill two of them.
一个估计说纽约市大约有200万只老鼠。我们花了一个小时才杀了两只。
Come on. Let's go.
来吧。走。
We try a couple more spots. We slip into a construction site through a gap in the fence. To me, as a New Yorker, this feels very wrong. Like, you don't go to these places in the city, because rats. They have their corners of the city. We have ours. They are in the subway tracks. We are on the platform. They're in the shadows, and we stay in the lights. It feels physically hard to force myself into this territory.
我们试了几个更多的地方。我们通过围栏上的缝隙滑进了一个建筑工地。对我来说，作为一个纽约人，这感觉非常不对。就像，你不会去城里这些地方，因为老鼠。它们有它们在城市的角落。我们有我们的。它们在地铁轨道里。我们在站台上。它们在阴影里，我们待在光里。强迫自己进入这个领土感觉身体上很难受。
I want to die. I want to die.
我想死。我想死。
Catcher is carrying around a dead rat.
捕获者正带着一只死老鼠到处走。
Where are we? What is this?
我们在哪？这是什么？
We're in some kind of an enclosure. It's really smelly and dirty.
我们处在某种围栏里。这真的很臭很脏。
Freeze. Everybody freeze. Freeze. Hold Ray right there. There's a rat ready to come out.
冻住。所有人冻住。冻住。就在那里抓住雷。有只老鼠准备出来。
Ray sniffs around haphazardly. Here's his mic.
雷漫无目的地四处嗅。这是他的麦克风。
[PANTING]
[喘气声]
Looks up at Judy.
抬头看朱迪。
I think he's done.
我觉得他完成了。
What did he do?
他做了什么？
Nothing. He's looking for food. He's not looking for rats. Oh my god.
什么也没做。他在找食物。他不在找老鼠。天哪。
But then we come to this dark alley. And this time, they specifically set it up for Ray to make a kill. Judy and Ray Ray stay just inside the alleyway. Behind us, there's a guy peeing into a dumpster. At the end of the alley is one of the dog owners, Susan. She looks so out of place. She's in shorts, white running shoes, standing in the middle of a pile of garbage, poking at it with sticks. She's trying to flush out a rat for her dog to catch. Judy, Ray, and I just watch.
但后来我们来到这个黑暗的小巷。这一次，他们专门为雷设置了一个捕杀。朱迪和雷雷就待在巷子里。我们后面，有个家伙正对着垃圾箱撒尿。巷子的尽头是其中一个狗主人，苏珊。她看起来太不搭调了。她穿着短裤，白跑鞋，站在一堆垃圾中间，用棍子捅它们。她正试图把老鼠冲出来让她的狗抓。朱迪、雷和我只是看着。
See, she really gets in the garbage over there.
看，她真的钻进那边的垃圾里。
Yeah. She's good. She really entertains her dog.
是的。她很好。她真的取悦了她的狗。
We're just seeing this so differently. Judy is thinking, that's amazing. I'm thinking, that's disgusting. Here's how Ray's feeling as he's watching.
我们看到的太不一样了。朱迪心想，那太棒了。我心想，那太恶心了。这是雷在看的时候的感觉。
[WHINING]
[呜呜声]
No rats run our way, so Judy decides, screw the battle plan. She's going to let Ray off leash, and tears off to find the other dogs in the garbage pile.
没有老鼠跑向我们，所以朱迪决定，去他的战斗计划。她要放开雷，冲去垃圾堆里找其他狗。
One rat emerges from the scrum and runs under a stack of loose boards next to the sidewalk. Ray heads in after it. This is the sound of him banging his head and paws under those boards.
一只老鼠从混战中跑出来，跑到人行道旁边的一堆松动的木板下。雷追在后面。这是他撞头和爪子撞那些木板的声音。
[POUNDING]
[撞击声]
Come on, Tanner. Go around.
来吧，坦纳。绕过去。
[SCURRYING]
[奔跑声]
[SQUEAKING]
[吱吱声]
Get 'em! Get 'em! Get 'em!
去抓它们！去！去！
I'm just going to pause things for a moment here, because what happened next goes really fast. And amazingly, we actually have a picture of this exact moment that Bill took with some kind of high-speed camera. The picture shows two dogs, Paco, Ray, and one very large New York City rat. The rat looks like it's doing some move from The Matrix , like slow-motion flying through the air, twisting at the waist, right across Paco's face, trying to escape his assailants. And then--
我在这里暂停一下，因为接下来发生的事非常快。而且令人惊奇的是，我们确实有比尔用某种高速摄像机拍到的这个精确时刻的照片。照片显示了两只狗，帕科、雷和一只非常大的纽约市老鼠。那只老鼠看起来像是在做黑客帝国里的动作，就像慢动作飞过空中，腰部扭转，穿过帕科的脸，试图逃离攻击者。然后——
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
[INAUDIBLE] Tanner!
[听不清]坦纳！
Good. Good. Good! Good! Good boy! Judith, wonderful.
好。好。好！好！好孩子！朱迪丝，太棒了。
Ray doesn't kill the rat. He misses him. But he pushes the rat right into Paco's face. I'm going to give Ray Ray an assist on this one.
雷没杀死那只老鼠。他错过了。但他把老鼠正好推进了帕科的脸。我会给雷雷助攻一个。
You did it, Ray.
你做到了，雷。
Yeah! Woo!
耶！呜！
Yay! Can we go home now?
耶！我们可以回家了吗？
Leave it, Tanner.
离开它，坦纳。
Tally-ho! Tally-ho. He wants back in. He's going after him. He's got the gene turned on now.
看哪！看哪。他想要回去。他正追着它。他现在把基因开启了。
Ray's passed the test. He's a hunter. He circles back to the blood on the sidewalk.
雷通过了测试。他是个猎人。他转回人行道上的血迹。
Oh, wow. That's-- he's licking the blood.
哦，哇。那是——他正在舔血。
Yuck! Don't drink the blood.
呕！别喝血。
I saw this quote in an article about terriers from the poet A. E. Housman. "I can no more define poetry than a terrier can define a rat." Ray has found his poetry.
我在诗人A·E·豪斯曼关于梗犬的文章里看到过这句引语。“我可以定义诗歌，就像梗犬可以定义老鼠一样。”雷已经找到了他的诗。
Judy puts Ray back on the leash. She seems a little shaken up, and she's ready to leave the Ryders Alley Trencher-Fed Society and go home.
朱迪把雷放回皮带上。她看起来有点震惊，她准备离开莱德胡同挖掘喂养协会回家。
I'm dirty. I'm smelly. I'm tired. I'm thirsty. Now I have to give my dog a bath. I want to get home and wash my hands.
我脏了。我很臭。我很累。我很渴。现在我得给我的狗洗澡。我想回家洗手。
Judy and little Ray Ray get in a taxi back to their apartment. Richard says he's seen her kind before.
朱迪和小雷雷乘出租车回到他们的公寓。理查德说他以前见过她那样的人。
I doubt she'll be back, but you never know. We get a lot of people like that who come, whose dogs show promise, but you can tell that they don't have the--
我怀疑她不会回来了，但你永远不知道。我们有很多那样的人，他们的狗表现出希望，但你能看出他们没有——
It's like their dog has the instinct, but they don't.
就像他们的狗有本能，但他们没有。
Well, I don't think she's a hunter. The dog is much more of a hunter than she is.
嗯，我不觉得她是猎人。狗比她更像猎人。
A few days later, Judy emailed us that Ray wasn't playing with his toys. I've been worried about this-- that there would be some irrevocable change in him. After tasting blood, his squeaky ball would just seem pathetic. But a few days later, he was back to his toys and Judy and Ray are going rat hunting again. This surprised me. It makes him happy, she said. She wants him to be happy.
几天后，朱迪发邮件告诉我们雷不玩他的玩具了。我一直为此担心——会有某种他不可挽回的改变。尝过血后，他的尖叫球会显得很可悲。但几天后，他又回到了他的玩具里，朱迪和雷又去捕鼠了。这让我惊讶。这让他开心，她说。她希望他开心。
When he and Judy walk down the street now, they are having exactly opposite experiences. I imagine what's in Ray's head as this X-ray version of New York City. Legions of rats running just under the sidewalks, in every courtyard, behind every stack of garbage. When he smells the air that comes out of the subway, he knows they're there.
当他和朱迪现在走在街上时，他们有着截然不同的体验。我想象雷脑海里那个X射线版本的纽约市。成群的老鼠跑在人行道下，在每个庭院，在每堆垃圾后面。当他闻到从地铁里出来的空气时，他知道它们在那里。
Judy, meanwhile, like all New Yorkers, lives surrounded by rats and tries her best to pretend they're not here. But for Ray, she'll cross over, look at the world as a terrier might, the same way you see couples walking down the streets of New York, hand-in-hand, one suffering through something the other one needs, just in order to feel like themselves.
朱迪，同时，像所有纽约人一样，生活在老鼠的包围中，尽量假装它们不存在。但为了雷，她会跨过界，像梗犬那样看世界，就像你看到情侣走在纽约街头，手牵手，一个忍受着另一个所需要的东西，只是为了感觉像他们自己。
Zoe Chace and Emmanuel Dzotsi are producers on our show.
佐伊·蔡斯和伊曼纽尔·佐齐是我们节目的制作人。
[MUSIC - "I SMELL A RAT" BY BIG MAMA THORNTON]
[音乐 - 大妈妈索顿的《I SMELL A RAT》]
[MUSIC - "THE 5TH QUARTER" BY THE MADHATTERS]
[音乐 - 疯帽子乐队的《THE 5TH QUARTER》]
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo. Our production staff, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvas, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, David Kestenbaum, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·福制作。我们的制作人员，佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇瓦斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、凯伦·达芬、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普戴克。
Editing help from Susan Burton, Julie Snyder, and Elna Baker. Our digital staff, Whitney Dangerfield and Julie Whitaker. Research help today from Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
苏珊·伯顿、朱莉·斯奈德和埃尔娜·贝克的编辑帮助。我们的数字员工，惠特尼·丹格菲尔德和朱莉·惠特克。今天的研究帮助来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
At our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
在我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，《This American Life》由PRX公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, what does he say about me quoting him here at the end of every show?
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，关于我在每期节目结束时引用他，他怎么说？
If he's not bored doing that every night, there's something wrong with him because I'd want to kill myself.
如果他每晚做那个不觉得无聊，那他肯定有什么毛病，因为我要是那样我会想自杀。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。